um how how did you guys meet oh it's a
pretty cute story do you want to tell it
Bob no you go for it Bob
you guys heard of nothing but do you
think is this fire hip-hop karaoke night
me and my girls were there a few nights
back and you know I was just chilling
fighting off an onslaught of dead guys
and just as I'm thinking right there
isn't a single decent guy in this entire
place I hear we have yes turns out one
of my girls put my name down as a joke
[Applause]
and it was just this immediate
deep animal attraction palpable Sexual
Energy Reckoning everyone in the room
could feel it really yeah really but you
know calling it a room makes it sound
kind of small
[Applause]
s and there was just like this sea of
people like a mini concert and when you
finish the crowd start trying
yes
[Music]
yes screaming
oh come on
they were going to tell the place out if
we didn't go again so we did like what
five six twenty more songs
well let's go behinds down the greatest
hookup story all the time
I have a question
you did karaoke
I guess you're right
people do change
foreign
[Music]